[Music]
[Applause]
I'm the one
all right so we've missed this uh this
thing called pbd podcast man we haven't
done it for a minute we had a crazy
event this last week I think it's fair
to say was the sickest Vault conference
ever Tom Brady Mike Tyson in the middle
of the interview saying hey yeah do we
do we have some time I said yeah why I
gotta use the restroom first time ever
he walks out the after party made no
sense it was craziness we had to shut
down the intercoastal making sure cops
didn't show up uh leaving at three
o'clock in the morning with plans of
what we're going to be doing next year
Tom Brady's interview
some of the questions that were asked uh
was very interesting Belichick was the
seventh ring more to win have one more
than Belichick or to have one more than
Michael your thoughts are what you're
thinking what I'm thinking he's going
after Belichick his former coach
I don't think it's MJ he respects do you
think he wants to be the greatest of all
time greatest of the greatest
he was careful because Bill Russell had
10 championships so if that's really
what his aspirations are he needs to
play four more years in the NFL
um there's one more above that too
um you know he tried very hard to be
Switzerland in his answer and he was
really selling it saying I cared about
the current one I cared about what I was
doing right then I cared about the game
I was playing right now really tried to
be but I think eventually Rob if you can
go to Twitter to show the painting that
we gave him at the end as a gift that
was sick he saw the daily mail picked
the story yeah just go to Daily Mail to
the Daily Mail
Brady yeah what's an article by the way
he wasn't unhappy when he found out I
was a Giants oh I didn't just let you
guys watch this so he didn't post that
vid so we got him this is the Tom
Brady's left stunned by Massive painting
of his career highlights as a future
Hall of Fame replaced on Mount Rushmore
by Lionel Messi Michael Jordan Tiger
Woods check this out go Lord that was
intentional by the way we wanted four
names on the Mount Rushmore
just press play on that I don't know if
they have the painting in there as a
picture if they don't
tiger Messi and Jordan okay on the Mount
Rushmore we had him as a kid we're in
Joe Montana's Jersey throwing the ball
we had him at the the draft it was
awesome giving him the gift because you
know this is a guy like we grow you're
saying this is your guy this is my guy
Kobe's my God we grew up when you're
when you're a fan and you watch a guy's
career you're going through it anyways
I'm so glad he liked it we had a great
event
and uh for those that were there you
know what I'm talking about Ken I'm
telling you wait till you hear what
we're doing for next year and we're
gonna announce Vault 2024 sooner rather
than later we had Senators at the place
we had the weirdest people at the place
ranging from regular businesses to doing
a half a billion year was a great event
can't wait to do it again audience like
the the actual caliber of people that
were there you heard from everybody they
were like wow like even the people that
buying like the cheap seats kind of
thing which aren't that cheap they're
like wow the caliber of people were here
and then everyone the CEOs
to the to the executive to the you know
what is it the general they were like
the shout out to this to the sales team
up there they're like one of these guys
the whole staff are just completely on
the wall it didn't matter who was if
they're dealing with you if they're
dealing with Vinnie if they're dealing
with anybody uh the the and by the way
let's not forget we'll get there we'll
get there a personality he cursed me I
will yeah you you use some bad words
against me man I don't appreciate it and
I'm just joking a lot of people were
like I was shocked by that I told
everybody wait till it ends will could
end up being your favorite speaker will
crush this 11 Madison shout out to him
making a comeback he's an operator
that's been there he's been to the
mountain he set his goal he got to the
top of the mountain yeah and just uh
random number one restaurant three
micheliness and put his flag on the top
of the mountain did a great job back to
Brady for a second what did you learn
about Brady that you just had no idea
before like for instance when we were
back dude he's tossing the football to
Dylan and Tico Pat did ran a post across
the
Randy Moss over here here's what I'll
tell people he's actually taller than
you she was God the guy is tallest
you're a legit 6'4 he's at least two
inches tall no he was he's tall he's
obviously with the shoes with shoes and
Slimmer remember and cleats are an inch
and a half too Rob can you pull up the
video and not to be controversial better
looking than I thought in person looks
like a statue I shook his hand my eyes
were where his Zipper was what would you
do about it would you do about it
I don't think that guy needs any help
with uh he's all the help he can get
it was actually it was actually you know
there was a part of it that was
emotional there was a part of watching
him you know talking about what he was
talking about he went on fire talking
about Drew Henson I mean that that whole
story he had to tell the details of it
yeah anyways yeah this is it by the way
uh NFL combine if you guys are watching
yeah I run a uh um
[Laughter]
with red bottoms
almost ran into the wall but oh yeah did
you almost like and you're on a carpet
dude that's not a joke
he just comes and he goes like this he
says Hey so pbd is daddy gonna run
around I'm like yeah I'll run a ride
Dylan runs go ahead press that right
there Dylan goes and he says
he says we got to go back let me see
that iPad Kelly thank you thanks Kelly
and then he does it again that's how
technical this guy was yeah he doesn't
play he's he's messing with an
eight-year-old now yeah oh sorry all
right look at Dilly
anyways we had a great time wish you
were there
and Pat yeah this is the Vault drink
everybody and their mother was drinking
this is my the this is the like launched
technically like everybody there was
drinking it well we'll do a full-blown
line football drink we've been drinking
for a few months just to fully before we
do that so anyways every podcast you're
gonna see is going to be sponsored by
The Vault Rings eight a day
all right let's go into a lot of stories
number one three people three different
people
uh others claimed that they could be
assassinated one Tucker claimed Trump's
about to be assassinated Russian
propagandist said Tucker's about to be
assassinated and Elon musk's father said
the way Elon is going he's worried about
Elon being assassinated all in the same
news cycle Tucker made a few crazy
claims about Barack Obama and what he
did with uh you know gay sex and crack
and he said some other things about
what's going on there we'll cover that
one maybe here in a minute Trump waves
arraignment uh pleads not guilty into
Georgia case the scientist team denies
Trump rumored that he'll drop out of the
race the Santa super Super PAC uh urgent
plea to donors we need 50 million bucks
uh uh then you got Trump World sees
Haley surging towards DeSantis uh
biographer says it wouldn't be a total
shock if Biden drops out Gavin Newsom
making some big moves we'll talk about
that here in a minute fauci Vinnie's got
an update for us with fauci uh roasted
as fraud and liar after being confronted
and damning study on masks uh what else
we got here resilient US economy defies
expectation Kevin only rewards chaos is
about to begin for U.S economy wake up
and smell the roses why youth
unemployment and uh surging in Russia
I'm sorry in China BMW Mercedes
launching biggest Evie push yet to catch
Tesla all income brackets now living
paycheck to paycheck and we talked about
musk musk said some things about his
daughter you know blames Elite La school
for brainwashing communist trans
daughter into hating him for being rich
by the way this school is fifty thousand
dollars a year per kid and then Wall
Street Journal story which is kind of
emotional and sentimental
they've been friends for 60 years Lou
and Bobby have figured out what most men
don't four out of ten men today don't
have a best friend if you don't have a
best friend we will be your best friend
here on paper podcast we're also looking
for best friends
Harvard happiness expert says there are
three types of friendship here's why you
need them all cover all of that anyways
okay let's go into some economy here Tom
Kevin O'Leary warns chaos it's about to
begin for U.S economy wake up and smell
the roses this is a fox business story
Kevin O'Leary chairman of all your
ranchers and Shark Tank star cautions
that the U.S economy is on the brink of
chaos due to Biden Administration policy
saying the month of September is going
to be chaotic for the economy he
highlights the disparity in government
Aid stating we've given we've given
nothing to small businesses early
rewards of the impact of small business
from rising interest rates noting fed is
raising rates up to five and a half
percent in a matter of months O'Leary
expresses concerns for small businesses
access to financing stating if you're in
the S P 500 you have no trouble
financing your business you can't say
that about small businesses anymore the
cost of capital has gone through the
roof he predicts a reduction in Regional
Banks from 4 100 to 2000 that's 50
percent leading to a public worry about
deposits and stating you're only
guaranteed 250 000 oily urges support
for small businesses recommending an
extension of the employee retention
credit saying wake up to the importance
of small businesses providing 60 percent
of jobs in America what are your
thoughts on this well there's a couple
things with Kevin O'Leary so and I'm
gonna take three of them self-interest
Chicken Little and the truth
so I feel like Karnak remember uh Johnny
Carson chronic magnificent would say
three things in the Antrim so let's
start with
um uh you know Chicken Little the sky is
falling there's things about that happen
in the economy and that's very very true
very true what's going on but the second
party talks about is um the employee
retention credit he's been involved and
he's been pimping for he does all these
commercials for that so he wants
extension of the employee retention
credit and he's running a service bureau
pbd that makes him money as a spokesman
so this is not the first time like uh
FTX where Kevin O'Leary's been a
spokesman that seems to have colored his
public comments but the one thing he's
talking about he's right on the the
truth part on the economy so setting
aside from Chicken Little grabbing
headlines setting aside from he's
actually as a service bro and getting
paid on the employee retention credit
the little conflict of interest there
he's right about the economy in small
business credit cards are one trillion
dollars job growth is actually slowing
interest rates are for houses even for
good
um credit around eight percent now for a
30-year fixed and the housing sales is
slow not coming back and he's right when
those interest rates are up there can
you imagine what it's like for a small
business person if it's an eight percent
mortgage and it a mortgage member is
backed up with a collateral called the
house
well small business people walking in
are looking at 10 11 and 12 uh loans
right now from Banks so he's right about
that and we already know about the
commercial real estate that's going to
be pinching the regional Banks and the
big banks are just going to buy them up
for uh discounted uh big stacks of uh
commercial real estate so he's right
about that and I think that what we're
seeing here is inflation still being
stubborn at about three and a half
percent
um we're going to get another quarter
point in one of the two uh upcoming
meetings of the FED which means that the
interest rates aren't going to go down
anytime soon so there's a lot of Truth
in what he's saying is that the end of
Q3 and going into holiday season
I'd like to know and I'm waiting with
baited breath to see what Black Friday
is going to look like what credit cards
are already at a trillion dollars it
feel like the consumer is running out of
gas and he's right those consumers who
are running small businesses got to fund
their own stuff too I like you gave sort
of a spectrum of where he is you called
it the Chicken Little then you called it
the what self-interest self-interest
Bingo and what's the third one the third
one is the truth because there's truth I
went right to number two
because
um the self-interest side of things
um there's a business model for this I
would call these these are like the
financial shock jocks the Doomsday
Preppers of Finance is that they are
motivated not to be prognosticators or
what you call Johnny Carson's back in
the day what do you call them
thanks but but basically uh you know
he's predicting the downfall of the
economy so if that is the case Kevin
O'Leary put your money where your mouth
is Sir do the Michael burry thing go
ahead and short the market do the big
short because anyone can just go out
there and be like get the sky is falling
the sky is falling and basically
um prey on people to buy your products
what's the product you said he's selling
uh employee retention credits he's a
spokesperson there you go have you got
your employee retention credit yet the
reason that we respect someone like
Michael burry on this podcast is because
he called it in 08 put his money where
his mouth is did The Big Short did a
movie and did it now again hundreds of
million dollars exactly so unless you're
that dude that is actually going to be
like the economy is going down where the
economy there's going to be in a
recession and you put your money and you
short the market shut your freaking
mouth and I respect Kevin O'Leary but
anyone could just uh the economies this
the recessions this it's like the
reality is nobody actually knows nobody
actually knows unless you put your money
where your mouth is it's all just hot
air and that's what I'm saying I wish
there's my last point I wish there was
some accountability for people who are
these Financial shock jocks Doomsday
Preppers of finance that we Circle back
and be like hey Kevin you said the
economy was gonna tank it's actually up
20 this year what do you say about that
like where's that we would all be part
of that camp by the way just so you know
that we would be part of that camp we've
talked about what could happen to the
market to the economy
um but you know what it is a part of it
for for for what you're saying with
Michael burry there's a reason why
Michael has that kind of respect too
short to Market you have a very good
point there uh Tom when it comes on to
next story here all income brackets now
living paycheck to paycheck a study
shows we're not talking like just
minimum wage this article is talking
about all income brackets now live in
paycheck to paycheck study done by
Lending Club Bank finds that inflation
mortgage rates over seven percent credit
card APR above 20 have let all income
brackets to the paycheck to paycheck in
July 2023 61 percent of U.S consumers
lip paycheck to paycheck up two percent
uh uh two percentage points from July
2022 the shares of low-income consumers
living this way Rose from 74 in July of
2022 to 78 percent among those earning
50 to 100 000 annually sixty five
percent live paycheck to paycheck in
July up from 63 percent High income
consumers earning more than a hundred
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars annually saw a small increase
rising from 43 to 44 study reveals that
regardless of income Americans need
their next paycheck to cover monthly
expenses due to Rising consumer goods
good costs and living expenses higher
interest rates have increased credit
debt to break the cycle downsizing
housing negotiating bills automating
savings and using high-yield savings
accounts are recommended let me read
that last part again
to break the cycle downsizing housing
negotiating bills automating savings and
using high-yield savings accounts are
recommended if if this is reading
correctly Tom this would validate that
eventually if people run out of a
savings and they're tapping into their
credit cards we're about to see this now
obviously the average person looks at
the market and says what what are you
guys talking about there's nothing going
on Market's doing good Market's doing
great bionomics is crushing it you know
maybe better than Reaganomics any of
that stuff what would you say to those
people I would say the S P 500 and the
stock market index has got nothing to do
with helping middle class America pay
their bills and what you're seeing here
we've been talking about it the middle
class is getting crushed and you look at
the lower part of the middle class there
now 78 almost 80 percent of that lower
band is living paycheck to paycheck and
almost two-thirds of the next band are
living paycheck to paycheck we've been
talking about the middle class is
getting crushed Commodities like eggs
and gasoline have come down everything
else has stayed up these people are
using credit cards to do it and suddenly
we've got like the statement you just
read
hey if you need to break the cycle
downsize housing sell your current house
to who no one's buying the interest
rates are too high for the next that's
the point negotiate your bills negotiate
with who the credit cards are getting
maxed out automate your savings how can
you save when you're using the credit
card to make up for the inflation pinch
on your common expenses and use high
yield savings account well that's nice
you've got nothing to save how do you
put it in there the middle class is
getting crushed and the inflation effect
on those two bands has been cataclysmic
and we'll mind you guys Pat you guys
have you know done pretty well for
yourselves I'm in that between 50 to 100
000 and I'm feeling it and seeing it
from every single thing patches going to
the Publix is going to the local
supermarket now I've never in my life
looked at Price this time on the shelf
and out loud but like are you serious
and other people in the aisles are like
teaming up going I never I'm starting
random conversations and they're not
coming down and they're not eggs did but
everything else Tom is not and it's like
yeah you guys because I think it was
live on this podcast guys Adam were the
White House remember the recession the
two quarters of negative growth well
they live change the the definition it's
like at what point do we admit it's
messed up and just come on and say like
Tom we're living in it right now and how
much is it going to affect uh the
election because I mean that's to me
that's that's the average American and
that's me and I'm feeling it I'll give
you this you know how Tom gave you know
three different things I'm gonna give
you two different things because you
know you all you always highlight that
the pbd podcast is different from the
sauce cast audience so I'll give two
different messages over here so some to
the younger single dudes out there and
then those to the family is out there
because those are different categories
because I you know I don't want to get
ripped a new one from PVD when I tell
people you can just Uber rather than
having a car payment for a thousand
folks brace yeah yeah so let them eat
cake says if you're young and you don't
have a family and you're just a young
Hustler guy or girl out there the key to
that life in America these days is
having low overhead and high flexibility
keep your costs low and your flexibility
High you don't know what the hell's
around the corner Andy Grove once said
only the paranoid survive whether Kevin
Kevin O'Leary is right or wrong on
Michael burry or the or Warren Buffett
who thinks the strong economy is strong
no one knows what you can do to control
your own pocketbook and your own
Financial Security is Keep Your Head on
a swivel see what's going on and then
also just stay the course as far as your
financial situation what I would also
say is those that have families those
that can't necessarily have that high
level of flexibility and um and the low
overhead because you are maybe fixed in
on a house you can't sell it you can
downsize on cars that's not what I'm
recommending uh specifically but there
is something going on in America today
and it's very interesting because you
know Andrew Tate highlighted it when we
spoke with him it's this sense of rugged
individualism that America's founded on
being an individual but also
um juxtaposed with a sense of family if
you remember uh Tate told that story
about the seven
um Muslim brothers that all lived in the
same house they pulled their resources
and they all lived together and they
worked together and they were all
driving fancy cars and doing fancy
things because they didn't have seven
different rents to pay so for those
people out there uh I do understand why
you want to be an individual so you're
saying take three families and live
together I'm just saying that we're
there is a lack of the the whether you
call it the nuclear family or the
familial unit like I know that you want
to buy it three different lots of your
properties right next to you and have
your dad there your sister there your
family there and all that you also very
highlight the the Asian family in your
community
I am saying that if if you do have kids
and you do have family uh they don't
need to necessarily rush to get their
own apartment and move out to college
and pay rent over here oh so don't kick
your kids out I'm just saying that the
family unit is the strongest thing we
have in America and it's very
interesting but we have this sense of
like oh you're 18 get the hell out of
the house I would recommend that young
people who are 18 stay in the house save
rent lower bills keep the food did you
talk to Tico and Dylan is this is this
what's popped up they're going to be
there until the 30. there it is yeah but
they can have girls over but the doors
must remain open I'm sorry yeah that's
the way it works especially Santa homie
yeah it's not happening no one goes on
the second floor go ahead but Pat like
think about it Adam in my 40s single but
whatever like when I'm telling you it's
feeling it right and module I don't
spend money on crazy stuff I have a
freaking Toyota Corolla Pad but the gas
the rent it's it's in it's getting
insane like I've been looking at the the
numbers it's getting really bad I'll add
one more thing everyone's like oh my God
what 63 uh paycheck to paycheck what's
the exact number 65 by the way it was
the same thing 10 years ago when I
started doing Financial content two two
out of three people are living paycheck
to paycheck that was under Obama that
was under Trump welcome to America this
is nothing new yes inflation's higher
wages have gone up a little bit this is
America people are overspending they're
not saving for the last 10 years since
I've been doing Financial content 50 of
Americans own Investments own stocks
that has not changed so your habits need
to change because America's not changing
it's it's an evergreen message that is
continues to to be given and it's very
necessary to be given I'm glad you're
making that adjustment so I think the
way if I want to unpack what I took away
from what you said yes sir parents three
families combine and live together
consider the religion of Muslim it's
kind of like where you were going with
that it's breaking news I'm converted
10 years ago what was the population of
America what's the population of America
now when the government steps in to
bridge this and give people relief
checks it's a bigger check for our
grandchildren and I'm just going to
leave it right there boom because the
population and the number of people that
are in these things is tens of millions
greater so it is a bigger problem when
you get a socialist president that says
we're going to print money bail you out
and pass it down to the grandchildren
okay let's go to the next story next
story
should we go to the youth unemployment
in China I think we talked about that
right yeah we do okay let's go to uh
let's go to Elon Musk blames Elite
schools for brainwashing communist trans
daughter into hating Kim for being rich
by the way these types of stories you
have no idea what this thing is I read
these types of stories
17 go to page 17. here we go
here we go Elon Musk attributes his
daughter uh Vivian Jenna Wilson's
distancing from him to her schools in
Florence dating she went beyond
socialism to be in a full-on communist
and thinking that anyone reaches evil he
discloses the the rift is deeply painful
comparing it to the loss of his first
child and laments have made many
overtures but she doesn't want to spend
time with me musk reveals that in April
2022 Wilson's transformation into uh
fervent Marxist led to breakdown in the
relationship he emphasizes her desire to
disassociate from him by changing her
name and gender and as she doesn't want
to have anything to do with me musk
singles at Crossroads School for arts
and science can you pull up the school
real quick Crossroads School and Arts
and Sciences as a contributing factor
indicating I partly blame the school for
her ideological shift he draws a
parallel between the school's influence
and his perception of Twitter which he
purchased uh uh uh later to defend free
speech and counter suppression time
you're a father of two daughters what do
you think about the story she will be
back on the long walk to the middle
trust me
um she will be back this reminds me of
the uh young girl who um ended up in a
viral Twitter pic she's sitting in an
airport with a MacBook Air expensive
sneakers holding a seven dollar
Starbucks with a big sticker on her
MacBook capitalism sucks yet capitalism
built everything that was in the picture
with her remember that yep and I feel
this is the same thing the whatever was
in that girl's head is what's in Iowa's
daughter's head you've got these you
know sixty thousand dollar a year
liberal teachers that think all rich
people are bad and so they're out there
telling these stories about it because I
don't know they think there's a money
tree and the government's just going to
give you Universal basic income and all
the things she wants including a MacBook
Air nice sneakers and a Starbucks as a
father you have to be active in your
kids and you have to tell them two
things why and when
and I work a lot with with uh with my
daughters on this is the why and the
when why are things like this and when
did it start and let them go see the
facts I've always said that I want my
daughters to have two abilities one is
to reason and the other is to resist and
if I tell them why and when and present
them facts and I'm big on processing Pat
was an influence on me on processing I
was even more focused on processing the
last five years as things have sped up
Pat but I want my kid to be able to
reason and resist because I tell them
why things started when they started so
they can go look it up in history for
themselves otherwise they're going to be
sitting in a classroom like this and and
getting bombarded my kids are going to
sit back and go no no wait a minute wait
a minute what are you saying there when
did that start why did that start what
are you talking about and they're going
to be asking that they're not going to
be saying oh you're messed up I love my
dad and you're full of crap no they're
going to reason right back at it why do
you think you said that don't worry
she'll be back like in the moderate Lane
on the long walk to the middle yeah the
she's going to come back because she
she's going to discover a desolate life
and minimum wage existence unless she
stumbles into some you know wealthy
artist whoops I almost went into Hunter
Biden land there
um and can go can go live her her life
she's going to come back to Dad and
realize when she's 30 years old just
she's going to come back and she can say
I'm sorry and she may still have her
liberal viewpoints but there's going to
be a Reconciliation and I call that the
long walk to the middle you go way to
the left and you slowly slide back to
the middle and suddenly you find your
father's not so crazy and I call that
that long walk back to the middle from
her point of extremism now which has no
consequence because she's a student
she's being supported there's all these
things she doesn't have to worry about
you know what I mean Adam you probably
see these people in a city like Miami if
a few of the Fringe by the way check
this out you know this we're going to
make it there she is I don't know if
that's actually her though but no no
that's the girl that's the viral picture
I was talking about so I I don't know if
I agree with you Tom and here's why
um you know Pat always says who's in
your ear who's in your ear who's in your
ear clearly she has the wrong people in
her ear and then you said all right
maybe she walks it back by age 30.
that's 20 years from now it's 15 years
from now she will be so far gone down
that rabbit hole of the LGBT wokeness
plus yeah she'll throw that Pew the Q
and The Pie
signs and an asterisk in there yeah
she'll throw it all in there and it it
might take a decade or two for her to
come back you know what one of the
things I love about what Pat says is
when you're young what you idolize your
parents then you grow to villainize your
parents she's clearly in the
villainization phase and at some point
maybe age 30 should begin to humanize
them but by age 30 uh she'll might have
gone through a
transgender reassignment surgeries
whatever I don't know what she he what
what they are but I think she may be too
far gone and and this goes back to the
private school thing it's so ironic that
you're paying 50 Grand a year for these
private schools for your kid to end up
like this and the most ironic part of
that is any any family that can afford
50 Grand a year for their family they
are capitalists they in order to afford
a school like that you have to be making
money you have to believe in free
markets you have to believe in
capitalism free market capitalism so the
the ironic part is that the kid will
then get indoctrinated to Market why put
your kids in a school like that but you
know what what I do like what are you
going to say well I was gonna say Pat
like this well people don't realize is
this is a regional thing where you know
where Crossroads is Right Pat this is
Santa Monica this is California right
just like all the all the right Bart
wrote a book on this school 18 years ago
I know people that I know people that
have you know this is a school that had
menage a prom like you go to school with
three trees and is this what you were
going to say exactly what exactly what
you're saying it's regional it's it's uh
Bill Maher was on Joe Rogan a couple a
couple days ago Pat and that's one thing
he said he's like it's regional in the
sense that you go to a dinner in
California Pat if there's 10 people to
dinner 75 of those kids are trans It's
all where they're at patent if they have
a cross-dressing day bill bill has a
cross-dressing day apparently like
according to this book written 18 years
ago yeah I mean I'll teed up for you
you've highlighted the increase in the
identifying as the LGBT community I
think 20 of gen Zen Z identifies as this
it's doubled in the last decade you're
about to say something no no what I was
going to say is I love that you're
saying she's going to come back to the
middle but I also love the fact that
you're saying she may never come back to
the middle and you you may lose her for
decades the reason why both ideas need
to be entertained as a parent is for the
parent you know so so think about it
this way think think about it this way
what's the longest you and I went think
about your best friend okay or one of
your best friends okay or a sibling okay
what's the longest you went you your
father your mother your best friend your
sibling what's the longest you went
without talking to that person well you
guys had a fallen out what was the
timeline just pick I don't don't give a
name who it is but what's the longest
human without talking to the two persons
I didn't talk five months okay I talked
to my dad for a few years we had a very
contentious relationship years what's
yours three years okay what's yours well
my brother like maybe two months three
months okay perfect okay so so sometimes
it happens with friends and you have a
friend you have a follow night you don't
talk for a month sometimes six months
sometimes 12 months sometimes it's just
like look man we grew apart just we
don't have the same thing but a falling
out is different than Grown Apart right
imagine the next time
you have a 15 year old daughter
the next time you're able to have a
friendly dinner with her is when she's
35. it's crazy odd okay lifetime you are
45 years old you are not gonna have
another dinner with your daughter till
you're 65 years old
let me let me let's do basic math one
day my dad is at the house
and I'm spending a Sunday with them in
La used to just on uh Texas he used to
only come once a month and sometimes
once every other month so once a month
he would come in it would say three days
and I had to have a Sunday with him I'm
looking at my dad sitting right there by
the couch and one day I just take a
paper and pen and I calculate how many
days I have left with them okay not not
days he's gonna live days I'm gonna be
around him okay then I did that with my
kids and I said how many Christmases are
we gonna have together how many more
days are these guys gonna be in my house
together watching these guys running
around doing all this stuff right and
after 18 it's gone right it's just
period con you spend 18 years with them
and then when they leave you're going to
spend God knows how many times or maybe
two years in the rest of your life I
cannot even imagine going 20 years with
not having a good relation with my
daughter by the way it's happening to a
lot of people because a few different
reasons one parents don't have the
ability to put them in a Christian
private school do you know right now
every Christian private school here so
when we first moved to Florida it was
open like there was not a waiting list
today you can't get in
let me put it to you this way Christian
private schools have so many
applications right now they can't take
more people wow they don't have a
problem with inventory right now that
their problem is we don't have room we
don't have teachers we don't have space
so so even some parents that want to put
their kids in private like I'm a
millionaire we understand so is
everybody else that's trying to put
their kids into school we don't have any
room right now okay that always tells
you how much parents are worried about
putting their kids in public schools
today how concerning it is but this
whole dialogue exchange between Tom and
Adam I I believe both ideas need to be
entertained by every parent and not just
assume they're going to come back assume
they are going to come back but if
you're 45 years old you got 40 more
years to live you lose 20 of the years
of spending time with your kids that's a
quarter of your lifetime and that's 50
of whatever you have left you best be
entertaining and monitoring who your
kids are talking to who's in their ears
by communicating with them regularly if
you're not involved in their day-to-day
lives this is how they get lost the more
you talk to them and you say hey what
did you learn today who were you talking
to who's your best friend what teacher
what did this teacher say parent-teacher
conference actually go like the other
day I went to the parent-teacher
conference and guess what I'm looking
for when I watch these teachers I was
watching see how weird they are so you
know it's all I'm looking for I feel you
look okay yeah she's fine okay yep he's
a music yeah he's a little butt it's
called he's fine okay this one okay and
then I walk out with the music teacher
so tell me about your family I got
married two kids 30 years oh great
that's great how about you you have to
take inventory to ask the questions to
learn so you know it's not like a risky
situation no matter how much you do
there's still risks because somebody if
somebody wants to do something they can
still do it yeah but you got to do your
part anyways good commentary one more
thing the difference between basically
when we were growing up in the 80s 90s
what have you versus today is that if
you're gonna fall out with a friend or
your dad or your mom or whatever you
come back you know two three five ten
years later you're a grown-up you're the
same person you've matured now when you
come back you might literally be a
different sex you leave as a daughter
and you hey my son's here you leave as a
son my daughter's here that is the
biggest concern today it's not even just
audio logical family fighting it is now
full on gender reassignment you're a
completely different human not just a
grown-up version of yourself a god Pat
yeah I just want to go ahead and besides
a family uh sense of it with you know
father son and she's transformation
she's a fervent Marxist which I've been
hearing that that they're teaching that
hardcore and all these liberal schools
back well we fail to understand those
kids grow up these are privileged kids
they're be they're the ones that are
going to be going into Congress and
Senate and that's why all the problems
that we're seeing is as these people's
attitudes are turning the country into
they want to be Communists you know what
I mean no I was nodding in agreement
with Pat and just um okay I've got
nothing for that by the way where are we
going here just so just so the fact that
you're hearing this story any minute
down the next 30 minutes we can have
Billy Bush who is the uh family brew and
Distilling Company and had a in an heir
to the Anheuser-Busch multi-billion out
of Fortune he'll be joining us in a few
minutes here to discuss what happened
with Dylan Mulvaney I just got a couple
questions for him we'll spend 15 minutes
with him we'll get back very ironic
story so yeah that's exactly what I
brought it up so fauci let's talk about
fauci fauci roasted as fraud and liar
after being confronted by damning study
on masks so how odd oh let's take a look
at this let's take a look at this on
fouchy you know what he's doing this
stuff flip his flop
okay so uh Dr Anthony fauci faced
backlash on social media after admitting
on CNN that his study showed masks had
limited impact on the overall course of
the kova 19 pandemic while acknowledging
weaker data for pandemic wide effects
fauci maintained that individual level
studies indicated masks could offer some
protection critics including Senator
Rand Paul and commentator seized on
fauci's statement labeling him a fraud
and a liar they highlighted the apparent
inconsistency of his stance masks
working individually but not on a larger
skill leading to accusations of
deception and mistrust fauci's shifting
Mass guidance during the pandemic also
fueled controversy initially downplayed
Massacre Effectiveness due to shortages
later endorsing them as supplies
increased Vinnie uh well first I've been
calling him flip-flop fouchy for for the
longest time it's like okay he's retired
am I am I right Rob he's finished he's
not even supposed to be it's just weird
that now that all the stuff that we're
hearing about is this the clip by the
way this is the clip and path do me a
favor while he places look at how creepy
this guy's eyes are on the left but look
at look at fault you're a retired guy
but they keep blowing him out whenever
something about it let's see what comes
out uh Brett Stevens in the times talked
about Cochrane put that on the screen
the most rigorous and comprehensive
analysis of scientific studies conducted
on the efficacy of masks for reducing
the spread of respiratory illness
including covid-19 was published last
month its conclusions said Tom Jefferson
the Oxford epidemiologist who is the
lead author were unambiguous there is
just no evidence evidence that they
masks make any difference he told the
journalist Mayan demasi full stop but
wait hold on what about the n95 masks as
opposed to the lower quality surgical or
cloth masks makes no difference none of
it he said well what about the studies
that initially persuaded policy makers
to impose Mass mandates they were
convinced by non-randomized studies
flawed observational studies how do we
get beyond that finding of that
particular review
yeah but there are other studies Michael
that show at an individual level for
individual when you're talking about the
effect on the epidemic or the pandemic
as a whole okay the data are less strong
you made no sense it's a nothing salad
wait a minute wait a minute individual
level individuals just came out I don't
know if you saw this this thing just
came out Vinnie if you saw this one here
uh uh from CDC apparently breaking CDC
has stated that Americans who have had
received the MRNA coveted vaccines are
now at a high risk of infection from new
variants of the virus and those who
aren't vaccines oh so you're talking
about Jill Biden Pat who yesterday
tested positive can you verify this go
for it Jill Biden uh don't I'm pretty
sure vaccinated in every single booster
shot she's probably in line for another
booster but this goes to my question is
Americans are we going to are you going
to comply when they try to bring this
back because you know it's coming back
these are the signs the uh first lady
Kobe it you wheel out fauci he's trying
to be like well I said it but I did but
I didn't say it I this is going to be a
beautiful test to see if Americans are
going to bow down and do exactly as
they're told again because it's starting
to come back uh Philadelphia is doing it
oh I'm seeing my mom flew recently she
said people at the airport already
starting to wear the mask it doesn't
work and I sent rob a video Pat of uh a
fauci this is mid pandemic during the
pandemic saying on 60 Minutes mask
nobody during a pandemic should be
wearing a mess because they don't
interrupt you have that that little clip
I I sent it to you it's like hey how
many times are we going to let these
people flip-flop uh Tom and then zero
accountability and why do we keep
willing them out he's retired like get
we don't want to see you anymore can you
show it really fast right now in the
United States
people should not be walking around with
masks
you're sure of it because people are
listening really no closely to this
right now people should not be what
there's no reason to be walking down
with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people feel a
little bit better and it might even
block a droplet but it's not providing
the Perfect protection that people think
that it is so so interesting so so what
was the date that was Martin of 2020.
yeah mid pandemic so no no not mid like
very early right March of 20. very early
but but even does it does it matter if
the head hey that's Mr science says you
don't it doesn't work if it doesn't work
then what's the point and then my real
question I'm being genuine then what
what is it is it a show of their power
of like they could mess with us whenever
they want because if it doesn't work
what's the point why yeah good question
I think look as the um
the President George W bush once said
you know fool me once uh you can't uh
You Can't Get Fooled Again tourists uh
you know you know fool me once yeah uh
shame on you for me uh twice shame on me
so look I think what happened to kova
just taking like kind of a step back it
was so new it was so weird we've never
seen anything like this first time in
100 Years of pandemic people are told to
trust the science you know operation
award speed Trump you got fauci out
there doing his thing it's just like you
have uh Dr Burke's other people didn't
have no clue no clue how to get a shot
don't get a shot I don't know you gotta
travel if you want to leave the country
like but I feel to use the George W bush
and Can't Get Fooled Again yeah uh I
feel like if this happens again yeah
people are like nah bro you you really
have not much faith in the average
American I do okay I don't they're gonna
they're gonna bow down and this comes
down to what I was gonna say there's a
difference between choice and mandates I
think we can all agree this is not a
country where mandates play well if you
want to get vaxed if you want to wear a
max if you want to put a face diaper on
your face as they say more power to you
do your thing if you're like nah dude
that's not for me I don't want to get
vaxxed I don't play that game
then that's on you like look Jill Biden
has coveted now yeah my mom just got
over coveted yeah certain people close
to us in the vicinity of valuetainment
have had covet it's a real thing yeah
and whether you get vaxxed or whether
you don't get facts that's your choice
but I do not believe in mandate well
you're and I understandable you're
saying that now Adam what I'm saying is
is when like you said yeah that chaos
that Madness and then I mean they knew
what the hell was going on they know
what what the deal is they were
mandating it you couldn't fly Adam you
remember if you're on an airplane and
you even try to lower your mask they
were on top of you right and some people
I saw I was on a flight coming here at
them they kicked the dude off he's like
I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not wearing a
mask they kick them off so I mean we've
changed my curiosity is when it hits the
fan again and it's coming because the
new ba whatever the app for the Sheep
it's the new one let's see how Americans
Rob can you go back to what you just
pulled up when I said can you verify
this that one article let me read this
year based on what can you please read
that uh sure this is from cdc.gov based
on what CDC knows now existing tests
used to detect and uh detect and
medications used to treat covid-19
appear to be effective with this variant
ba286 may be more capable of causing
infection in people who have previously
had covid-19 or who have received
covid-19 vaccines and again that's from
cdc.gov that's from CDC that's the CDC
so go out and get an unvaccinated so
you'll be safer yeah how do you do that
but but can't get pulled again and
here's my thing here here's the here's
what the average American is thinking
not conspiracy theorist coincidence
theorists isn't it it's a weird
coincidence that now we're getting close
to election year this is the this is the
test this is the oh there's another
variant put on the mask the the the the
first lady has it at what point is it
going to get that we're like oh God
pandemic number two is here you gotta
stay home nobody leave your house vote
from your house and mail-in balance but
that I'm telling you guys right now
that's where they're leading up to I
don't know let's let's wrap this up with
one thing you know the weatherman can
say can pop that
um
Malik pop that one back up uh I'm in CDC
we're gonna go to the next to last
statement real fast
um you know it can rain
or it can be a hurricane right and right
now it says here at this point there is
no evidence that this variant is causing
more serious more severe illness there
you have it so guess what there is a
direct link in all this to herd immunity
and that the variants out there are not
making people as sick as they used to so
when you say the word covid it's not
like saying rain versus hurricane the
Hurricane's over it may rain and they
rain for a couple days and you get sick
and by the way P.S China still has not
been held accountable I'd like to just
point that out what the hell is going on
in China it's not weird this is going to
point that out right there weird we
still Pat to this day wait you still
can't even save that type of stuff for
being racist where is the accountability
for work you know what was what was the
most funniest thing is when when that
one uh time when Trump says it's called
the China virus yeah and then it says
sir you can't call it China that's
that's discriminating against the whole
population we have in America and then
the report journalist reporter who's
Chinese Asian lady said it's called
China why would you say that to me
remember that would you say that to me
because I'm Chinese no it's because it's
from China yeah and and then story comes
out it's from China you know okay so
we're gonna go is that the one is that
the one that's the one can you just play
that that's not the age no that's not no
no I know it starts with that and she's
the last one oh I got you go play it
from the beginning she's cute watch this
are you calling this the Chinese virus
there are reports of dozens of incidents
of bias against Chinese Americans in
this country your own age secretary
does not cause the
viruses
it's not racist at all no not at all it
comes from China
they don't have the Asian leaders
like why are you looking at me when
you're saying she's like China yeah well
weird it was right it's like in the 40
year old version he's like what's your
revenge next story we're not going to go
back to the history books and we're race
the Spanish flu or erase the Hong Kong
theater or the great insult to pigs
around the world the swine flu exactly
shout out to Monkey pox though what
Vinnie got that one yeah let's let's
talk about let's talk about do we want
to talk about the friends let's talk
about the friends right now they've been
friends for 60 years Lou and Bobby have
figured out what most men don't do it
again that voice I love it
listen Lou and Bobby what a name Lou
lifelong friends Lou Wilcox and Bobby
Roebuck Jr who met a 1962 continued
their strong bond by spending Saturdays
together their routine involves
breakfast errands and heartfelt
conversations that reflect their shared
stories and understanding the decline in
close friendships especially among men
is evident with 15 lacking close friends
as of 2021 per the American perspective
survey societal Norms emphasizing work
and family over emotional sharing can
contribute to this trans saying
psychology Professor Michael Addis the
chemistry of friendships thrives on
shared experiences Lou and Bobby's
Journey includes growing up in similar
household facing illness face so in
other words have coveted with friends
and careers in law enforcement they
navigated differences openly and support
each other through lifelong challenges
they're enduring companionship serves as
a model for mental health and well-being
as they navigate together and by the way
go ahead I was going to say the article
that follows yeah go ahead go out yeah
so Harvard happiness expert Harvard
happiness expert there are three types
of friendships here's why you need all
of them the utility friendship those
that can pay your bills no I'm just
joking
yeah think about the relationship you
have with people with whom you work with
or with whom you do business with these
relationships tend to be transactional
in nature friendships based on Pleasure
I mean there's some words for this as
well right so this one comes with
benefit this type of relationship is
based on Mutual admiration because each
person draws pleasure from each other if
a person finds their friend funny
interesting in a source of enjoyment it
is likely a friendship of pleasure and
last but not least perfect friendship by
Aristotle standards perfect friendships
are those between people who have a
mutual love for something that not only
brings them together
but elevates their behavior of two
virtue a relationship is perfect not
when it is based on utility or pleasure
but when it is focused on improving the
circumstance of the other person so
what's going on I think we're all
perfect
why is this a headline I mean
Philadelphia Wall Street Journal no no
but think about it Philadelphia was
known as the City of Brotherly Love for
people in a tough environment would back
each other up help each other out help
each other with kids and family and
stuff and that's what you do it used to
be called Neighbors it used to be called
Community yeah and when you go to the
Bible the Bible talks about three types
of Love agape and Eros Eros is erotic
love between you know your spouses Agape
is like God's unlimited love for us so
much he was willing to die for us and
then phileo is exactly what he's talking
about that's where we get Philadelphia I
don't understand why it is such a news
flash that when people come together in
community to really support each other
whether you both love the Philadelphia
Eagles you go to ball games together or
you both have teenage kids and you're
getting through that together or you're
supporting each other one person gets
laid off you're helping them out find
jobs I don't understand why it's such a
news flash that what was once a core of
America knowing all your neighbors names
and being connected to them and
supporting them is is a headline now and
I think it's great that they're
highlighting the long-term benefits that
these two guys have had because if
America will come back to this Spirit of
community I think there'd be a lot of a
lot of benefits to the psyche of people
getting through recessions
covid and all these things because you'd
have more friends and more support yeah
I don't know I mean I don't know what's
going on with these two gay guys Lou and
Bobby but these guys have been living
together for six years let's do that I
don't know Lou Wilcox and Bobby look
back in the Army at my my friend
lieutenant
that was like I don't know about this
Wilcox guys but look here's what I will
say
um speaking of the three friends I know
that you got all biblical on friendships
Tom I'm gonna you know bring it back to
the real world that was only one of my
points
I'm not arguing with you Athos Pathos
and uh fellatio
um fellatio so look there's three types
of friends I like how they pointed this
out you have your work friends yeah I
get it you know these are transactional
hey buddy what's up what's pandering to
them then I would say that you have like
your party friends hey what's up bro how
you doing let's go party but these
aren't like your best friends and then
you have the guys you can just sit on
the couch with and chill those are your
buddies uh I love what pitbull had to
say
because especially during covet we all
isolated you weren't around your friends
you weren't around your people and just
because you have social media doesn't
mean you're socializing yeah right you
need to get out there and have friends
and there has been a massive decline in
friendships so I think in the 80s
um
people had five or six close friends
today it's one or two at the most like
there's a limited amount of friendships
people just are not socializing outside
and then everyone's so obsessed with
having followers but the apps the
opposite of followers as being a leader
so get out there make some friends even
if it's like these two 60 year old men
over here I thought you were gonna say
you have friends you smoke weed with
some you do coke with some you drink
alcohol that's the direction you're
going for being from Miami
so there's loyal to begin I got you okay
no I mean listen as as crazy as it
sounds it was an article rob a couple
weeks ago we never got to it the whole
lonely uh epidemic if you remember that
article I think we were trying to
comment on it for a couple weeks we
forgot about it I obviously forgot about
it but uh it was a story about the fact
that a lot of people are lonely nowadays
right America has a lonely Problem
whatever the article was was it the
article from Scott Galloway where it's
like this the most dangerous no that
wasn't the one it was another one lonely
isolated by the way it is true though
there are a lot of people that don't
have friends there is an element look I
remember I'm telling you from even from
the business standpoint when I started
PHP the beginning stages oh my gosh
being introduced to a vistage or a group
of people we'd sit there and talk about
problems of running a company having
kids family and then you're all of a
sudden saying to yourself man I'm not
the only person going through this I
thought I'm the only person because I
have to battle with being lonely you
think you're the only person that's
going through this problem you think
you're the only person that's facing the
embarrassing humiliating breakup
challenge issues struggle and then
eventually you're like no man there's a
lot of other people out there you know
this whole concept of AAA when it got
started is other people have a similar
issue like you as well but collectively
together we can get through this and
that system a a big part of it is
faith-based matter of fact it is
faith-based has saved so many people's
lives right because you go in there and
say oh you got a prompt too you got a
problem that that's a normal guy that
guy's an executive that guy said wait
she's going through this are you kidding
me that wow I am not alone so it's great
to have these types of conversations but
I will say to you go find a community
everybody needs to be part of a
community God knows we need it yeah
you're going to say something and Adam
you killed the two of the social media
because Pat think about it you if you're
home and you're one of these guys your
phone you can do you can see everything
you could you could have virtual this
video game at your house you literally
have to make a conscience effort to go
get the hell up and get the hell out
just just yesterday bro Adam I woke up I
heard a band and people playing I live
by myself I went to the there's like a
local farmers market with a band that I
met people and then I had people over
for dinners you have to get out and I
just want to say that I'm happy that I
think you guys are my perfect friend
thank you uh thank you appreciate that
I'll add one last thing because I know
we gotta go see Billy Bush
um
it's so easy to just not leave your
house these days it is so easy there's
never in the history of the humanity
have you never had to leave your house
you don't need to go get a girlfriend
just watch porn online you don't need to
have friends just for just communicate
with your friends on Tick Tock and on
Instagram you don't need to go shopping
just do it instantly go to Amazon
there's no reason to leave your house
unless you actually want to be a real
human being yeah like one of the things
I love about Pat is you had your boy
Manny there at uh the vault 21 years
you've had Felix in the office whether
it's alpha or Steve or Armand these guys
even know for 20 years I this Sunday I
went to go see my buddies they were
having a fantasy football draft I do not
participate because it's a waste of time
yeah I just hung out with these guys and
ate chicken wings while they called me a
trump fan for two hours I was like yeah
I'm the drunk guy like like but the part
of having friends is being able to bust
balls be a dude and like shoot the
with your homies and you can't do that
online no at all and it's horrible and I
think about those those are the friends
that you're supposed to sit and talk
with and have go through your problem
here people I don't know that they go to
psychiatrists they sit there and they
talk to somebody that's what your
friends are afford do you want us to
turn off the podcast and just please
spend the moment together friends and
how many people have that do you
actually remember the words of that song
Friends
yeah there you go good okay so uh let's
go through a a story of a company called
Nvidia Tom I'm gonna come to you with
this one here because I know you got a
lot of thoughts on this and Vinnie if
you can get your reports ready
you got the TPS reports by the way I
think this is a an excellent story to
get into to transition into our next
story Nvidia crushes analyst expectation
in second quarter earning report uh uh
their Q turning report released on
August 23rd reveals a remarkable already
88 surge in Revenue to 13 and a half
billion dollars accompany accompanied by
an impressive 203 increase in net income
to 6.1 billion dollars their margins are
50 notably data center Revenue also see
substantial growth soaring to 140 by 141
compared to previous quarter gensen
Huang founder and CEO of Nvidia
emphasizes the Advent of a new Computing
era driven by accelerated Computing and
generative AI he States the race is on
to adopt generative AI analysts from wet
Bush Securities describe the results as
pivotal moment for the tech sector with
ripple effects expected to impact the
industry throughout the end throughout
the year despite the outstanding
performance Nvidia Nvidia Nvidia
acknowledges supply and demand
challenges for its AI chips demand
surprise surprises Supply by 50 and
concerns arise over possible export
restrictions to Chinatown what can you
tell us about what these guys are doing
so here's what's going on
um AI needs a power source that power
source is chips and Nvidia makes more
and better chips for Ai and anybody else
it's that simple this is like Intel do
you remember the um all the ads used to
see grown up pad Intel inside and yeah
little robots dancing around and the
Next Generation the 286 386 the Pentium
chip that was the Heyday for Intel
because Intel had the technology
powering this thing called the personal
computer Nvidia is powering this thing
called Ai and they're a leader like
intel was remember when the Microsoft
was on a roll and every time they had an
earnings report they would crush it
again including a time when a reporter
saw a Balmer and Gates walking to the
elevator on the back side of a
conference area you know it's like the
elevators you use for security Pat and
they were high-fiving each other because
they had just convinced the analysts
that their quarter wasn't going to be as
good as it was going to be and the
analysts had kept raising the estimates
and their job was to keep the estimates
lower so you're going to grow 50 percent
I'm really think it's like 30 35 percent
I don't know could be cloudy tomorrow
and they were doing everything they
could so Microsoft had its Heyday Intel
had its Heyday now we've moved from the
Wintel standard for laptops we've moved
into cloud computing and AI chips and
Nvidia is the Intel of the future for AI
and that's for people listening that's
the way you look at it and so they are
crushing it and this is their this is
their run to the top so so if you look
at the stock if you look at this closely
which is obviously very impressive these
guys went from let's zoom in a little
bit by the way check this out from 2019
they're at you know whatever twenty
dollars thirty dollars whatever the
number is and then they go up to 141
then they go up and then they have a
drop off after covid you know big hit
and a boom now they're back up to 494
right these guys went from you know I
think it was a gaming company at one
point to semiconductors to now ai so the
whole idea about business is only the
paranoid survived but also the ones that
are able to make the right pivots in
business are also able to survive they
made the right pivots many companies
didn't make the right pivots by the way
this doesn't just apply for some of you
guys that are watching and saying well
I'm not running a billion dollar company
I'm doing this look when it comes down
to Content you have to make the right
pivot some don't they're done there's to
be a lot of people who have watched
content if you could go look at your
history I don't know if you can
from the content you consumed four years
ago to three years ago to five years ago
to ten years ago a lot of those guys are
gone a lot of those guys you're not
following anymore some people in content
didn't make the right pivots the same
happens with business the same happens
when marriage the same happens with
parenting the same happens with your
health and these guys get credit for
making the right pivots and now uh the
the
6.1 billion Tom on 50 margins they're
pretty much cash in like they're they're
a bank right now printing money the way
they're growing all right absolutely and
it's again we've seen this before but
what they did was for people that were
paying attention
what was going on in video game if so
everyone that saw Madden football
getting more realistic and more
realistic and more realistic you
remember this who's a gamer in here I'm
a Call of Duty and I play it okay hadn't
Madden football the players got more
lifelike more lifelike and then the rain
and then the textures and then
everything about the game that's why
they called it EA Sports It's in the
game if it's in the game on the field we
want to bring it into the PlayStation
and The Game Boy and the uh Xbox 360. so
Nvidia chips in there have been applying
these were called physics engines and
also Dynamic engines that were inside
video games to you know project the
bounce of the ball according to how
you're playing it not a movie but
according to what's happening and
nvidia's chips have been on this March
toward what they have today so what
started in video games with AI and
everything else they didn't just come
out of the garage and say oh look what I
just invented this is a company that is
an overnight sensation 12 years in the
making I'll add one thing and this is
basically a shout out to the Vault event
and pbd but one of my favorite parts of
the of the entire vault is when you do
the case studies and there was an entire
what like half hour long case study
debate argument State your case what
you're going to do and everyone in the
audience had the opportunity to say what
they would do to implement AI in the
company and Manny had an answer and yeah
uh uh other guy had an answer and a shot
had an answer and it was going back and
forth but that my friends is kind of the
reason we do this podcast is that's
where you find common ground that's
where you find the answer so I don't
know if you saw
um that Eric Schmidt who was the former
CEO of uh Google speak obviously they're
involved in the AI game was just on my
boys uh show for read Zakaria and he was
pointing out basically all the the pros
the cons of essentially AI I think
that's what we're in need of right now
is there's so many questions around AI
nobody knows is it good is it bad is it
going to change the world the robot's
gonna take over uh I think we need more
conversations and more specifically
debates around AI
uh Rob how we looking Rob
good we're just sound checking and video
checking real quick okay sounds good why
don't we just get AI so let's do one
story and then we'll go to that so
Google AI Chief warns genetic
engineering could bring deadliest
pandemics ever it's an interesting story
Mustafa Suleiman Google's AI Chief
sounds the alarm about a major Global
threat a super pandemic resulting from
genetic engineering he warns now within
the next decade it could become
commonplace for individuals to create
more lethal pandemics from home
stating a kid in Russia could download
the instructions set for pandemic
Suleiman uh unless underscores the
urgency of containment and success
Access Control saying we have to limit
access to the tools and the know-how so
lemon stresses the ability the
accessibility of advanced AI technology
noting its increasing affordability and
availability he highlights the potential
risk including cheating on exams
crafting viruses with Worldwide impact
driven by the open nature of the
technology to address these concerns the
advocates for an international treaty
involving not just allies but also
perceived adversaries like China and
Russia stating we all have a shared
interest in advancing the collective
health and well-being Tom
so I got two sides to this the first
side of this is maybe the guy's right
the second side of this is maybe Google
wants to be the biggest defense
contractor in the AI world and they're
like we need to have a shared interest
and a global treaty and limit access to
everybody else except us so that we can
dominate the space so I think I read
this story and my skepticism goes right
down the middle maybe he's right but on
the other side you know what maybe he's
just trying to to carve out a place for
go for Google and he's uh using Scare
Tactics to do it because limit the
access he's not talking about himself an
international treaty he's not talking
about being left out it's kind of like
saying so listen guys you can trust us
because we're responsible we're not
going to do anything we have to be
careful with the other people because at
Google we have your best interest in
mind even though we control Google
YouTube a lot of different companies we
know what's right for you is that kind
of what your interpretation is exactly
right from the company who Originals
Charter on the wall when there was only
six employees that got out of that
garage in Silicon Valley don't be evil
it was one of their tenants remember
that yes I do and they've been
embarrassed by that being waved in their
face how many million times literally
millions of times by pundits and
observers who think that they have done
evil in so many ways you think that's
Larry and Sergey they're being accused
of evil is that what you're saying
go go read the articles the buck stop
somewhere well I read the articles I got
the biz doc right here no I mean the
point the point is look what they've
look what they've done the manipulation
of YouTube look what they've done on
manipulation of AdSense somewhere
someplace in there they've said okay for
the profit motive we're going to do this
this we're going to do this we're going
to do the government called government's
on the phone they're a big contractor of
the Google data center they'd like these
four people to be taken off of um uh
YouTube and because they're talking
about vaccines okay I'll be right back
let's see let's see what happens there
but I know the whole evil line we have
Billy Bush here with us his newest book
family Reigns The extraordinary rise and
epic fall
of an American Dynasty available on
Amazon Rob let's make sure we put the
link in chat as well as the description
he is the founder of the Bush family
Brewing and Distilling Company and heir
to anheuser-busch's multi-billion Dollar
Fortune he's a proud father of seven
children and stars with his wife in the
MTV reality series the Bush family
brewed a graduate of St Louis University
he played professional Polo winning the
U.S open polo tournament he and his wife
Christy a film producer and head of bush
Productions live under 700 Acre state in
St Louis Missouri Billy thank you for
taking the time for being on the podcast
it's a pleasure Patrick thank you for
having me on yes so Billy you know
what's interesting just a couple weeks
ago Tom and I were at the UFC event with
Dana White and Dana uh introduces us to
uh the CEO of Anheuser-Busch Brandon
Whitworth which by the way seemed like a
friendly guy we had a good conversation
together with them and I asked them the
question and that I want to ask you to
see what perspective you have as an
operator myself running a company you
know you got a lot of direct reports
you'll have the CMO reports to you
you'll have the CFO reports to you
you'll have your Chief compliance
officer different businesses have
different Chiefs but you'll have all
these Chiefs that'll report to you know
sometimes you'll have Chiefs reporting
to other Chiefs but
how does the when a decision is made by
this Alyssa uh uh uh heiner shied a very
friendly last name when she decides the
VP of marketing to uh send these beers
to Dylan Mulvaney and Dylan Mulvaney
takes it and all of a sudden it's cost
at this point I don't know the exact
number how much billion no no it's it's
a lot of money that they've lost every
week the number changes because they
haven't fully recovered yet Billy for
you obviously your background will go
into the company but a decision like
that being made who does who has to give
the approval for that to go so meaning
is it more of a CEO responsibility the
CMO or is the CMO empowering the VP of
marketing to say look let's get the
product out on markets we're not in how
does that work out
well I remember back in the old days
that nothing went out until the CEO
approved of it and um you know I am
after writing the book family Reigns The
extraordinary rise in Epic fall of an
American Dynasty I am more close to my
ancestors and the people that ran out
Anheuser-Busch than I've ever been and I
understand it much better these days and
I just see that um you know that kind of
marketing nothing would go by the CEO
without their approval and I even
remember going with my father Gussy Bush
August Bush Jr he was the fourth leader
of Anheuser-Busch and going to
conventions and wholesaler
um uh meetings things like that and
seeing the hymns show the wholesalers
and people at the conventions what the
upcoming ads were going to look like
before they ever aired them and so they
had the ability to weigh in on the ads
so
um you know I just don't know how
something like that would have slipped
through the cracks with Brandon at
Anheuser-Busch inbev today but uh but of
course it did and uh look what happened
do you think do you think he knew about
it and he approved it or do you think it
happened without him knowing about it
I think he had to have known about it
Patrick I don't think anything happens
to that in that magnitude without the
CEO knowing knowing about it okay so
let's let's say let's say he didn't know
about it this is a guy that's a former
CIA guy he's a sharp guy he's not like a
lightweight he went to Harvard I believe
I think you know he's military
background he's a decorated guy so he's
got the military side he's got the
paranoid side of being on the military
NCI were you always skeptical and
wondering people's motives are you've
gone to Harvard so you've got a little
bit of the business background you've
done a ton of case studies what would
make him with the background that he has
say I think it's a good idea to send
Dylan Mulvaney you know a some Bud Light
and let's put Dylan's logo on it and
he's gonna probably end up liking it and
it's going to get us into a market we're
not knowing who his audience is is not
that
well I got to tell you if he's a CIA Guy
and
um and has been working
um in that branch and doing things like
that maybe he doesn't understand the
beer business that well maybe he doesn't
really understand who his audience is
um but you know as we've heard today you
know the CIA are very left they're doing
everything to help this Administration
uh succeed right now and um the Biden
Administration
um they're working against uh
conservatives and um we as we know this
is a very woke agenda that we're seeing
with the CIA so if he is part of that
agenda then it's obvious why he he went
with uh with with an ad like that I'd
follow up with this anytime I'm going to
turn it over to you I know you got a
couple questions for him as well so so
so for me I want to give him the benefit
of the doubt because when I spoke to him
Dana spoke very highly of him and when
I'm talking to this guy he seems like a
reasonable guy he doesn't seem like
somebody that doesn't know what they're
doing we had a good 10 15-minute
conversation together so how much of it
Billy could be the fact that nowadays
with ESG people are concerned about
their scores and you're looking at these
three companies that are pretty much
controlling the marketplace through
institutional investing I'm talking to
Vanguard State Street BlackRock the
Larry Finks of the world so they're
going out there and investing into these
companies and you have to create a
certain guideline and you got to have
this Dei score and this CEI score said
there's so much pressure to have that to
get on the right scoring so s p doesn't
downgrade your you know your ESG score
of course nowadays SMP saying we're no
longer looking at the ESG how much you
think was that versus how much you think
he said I think this is a brilliant idea
let's do it
well I think uh I think that absolutely
weighs into it when Blackstone and
Vanguard and uh the other company are
are part of and how much control they
have over these companies today and uh
what and their their agendas that
they're pushing and it's really sad to
see because uh if you listen to them
obviously they don't know the beer
business they don't know um even like
Disney Disney
um they don't know the theme park
business and uh and I do believe that
they have something to do with pushing
these kind of woke agendas on these
companies and um you know does it take a
really strong CEO to say no we're not
going to do that that's not what our
audience is all about our Bud Light
Drinker does not want a transgender on
on the on their beer can not you know
this it's um too political it's been
politicized uh over and over again with
men competing in women's sports and all
these things going on today so
um you know when my my family ran the
company and it's in the book they would
never get political in that way because
they didn't want to alienate 50 of the
population in America and that's what
these guys did and uh you know my family
was very much like Brandon I don't know
the CEO of Anheuser-Busch now but um
they were all you know my dad was a
colonel in the Army during World War II
my uh my great-grandfather even was a
Corporal during the Civil War for the
Union Army and so they all know about
the military they were all very much
American but you know they would never
politicize their ads they love this
country for what it stood for they
believed in Freedom they believed in uh
of course the rights to Big transgenders
and gays and who on and everyone out
there as long as you weren't hurting
anybody that's what this country's built
on but um to get into these kinds of
advertising just doesn't make sense and
and honestly Patrick I don't know how
they're gonna to come out of it I really
don't I think their sales or I know
their sales are still way down I don't
think they're making much of a comeback
at all and whether they get the Drinker
back and make that America's beer again
which my family works so incredibly hard
to build
um is um is yet to be seen yeah it's
interesting when I was in the Army 101st
Airborne all we drank was Bud Light and
I will tell you some nights we drank 23
the record is 27 but let's keep that
between us Tom you had some uh some
thoughts on this go forward you got some
questions but first of all I'd like to
say um as a Young Man
lived a couple years in Creve Coeur uh
when my dad's job had us there and uh he
and my mom took us to Grant's Farm and I
remember going there it was a wonderful
experience you know you felt tradition
you felt family there so thank you very
much for your family having that
wonderful essentially making it like a
national park but I see the tradition in
that and I also see oh you're welcome
and I also see the tradition in your
heart your at heart and what you've just
done with your own Brewery and an
entrepreneur at heart you built you
built one attempt it didn't work out so
well and now you have another one where
you've got two of these pilsner beers
out there gussie and Adolphus in tribute
to your family members and I look at
that and I see the heart of an
entrepreneur I see a heart of the family
and I want to ask you a question you
know Seagate Technologies was taken
private they went back and took it
private if you know about that company
out in Silicon Valley storage Michael
Dell took Dell back private took back
control of it you've made comments about
about Bud Light is there an opportunity
here for maybe the family to take back
because it was not an intentional thing
the family had sold its Holdings and and
you were in a position that many
companies are in where you could have
these hostile takeovers and ultimately I
guess they got the bid up to 71 and it
was to a point where the shareholder
vote nobody was going to vote against
that because it was such a premium to
purchase and as is you know uh August
the 4th tried who I think was your
nephew
um you became an uncle when you were
five years old I think as the story goes
um do you think about do you think about
the opportunity here like Seagate like
Dell to take a run back and bring this
back into the fold and show the the
American fan and customer
multi-generation customer that you're
going to take this back and you're going
to do something with it
well thank you for all your nice
comments there and uh you must have read
the book Tom because
um uh everything you're saying you know
is in the book I grew up on Grant's Farm
and I'm glad you enjoyed it there and it
was a wonderful place to grow up and had
a great time and I talk all about my
experiences in the book family Reigns so
check it out you guys are gonna love it
but yes I I will say that I do think
it's going to be a very difficult uh
quest for inbev now to um get uh Bud
Light rolling again
um I just go back in history and I I see
the accomplishments that my
great-grandfather grandfather father and
his brother
um how hard they worked how much they
loved the company how much they love
their employees
um how how they understood America and
Their audience how much they love this
country and uh no you could you could
live the American dream here and I think
that's one of the reasons I wrote the
book today is because you know people
forget how great this country is and um
I wanted people to understand that where
I came from and that is you can make it
if you work hard and you have a dream
and you have the faith and you have the
determination you can make it in this
country you can do great things you've
got a really really good chance to do it
anyway and so um I never worked directly
at Anheuser-Busch I didn't have that
opportunity and if you go back into look
again you can see why I wouldn't have
had that opportunity yep but I did work
um at two distributorships
um and uh you know delivering beer to
the customers to the bars and the
restaurants and the grocery stores and
um liquor stores and what have you all
the different convenience stores of
course and I got to know the people I
got to understand the industry and that
I was also also grew up on the
entertainment side of the business at
Grant's Farm uh keeping the place
beautiful and maintained for guests that
would come the seven months of the year
we were open and then like you said I
had my own company uh the William K Bush
Brewing Company with my family and you
know we made a heck of a college try and
making a goal with that company it
didn't work out so we've kind of changed
the model now with the Bush family
Brewing and Distilling Company inviting
people out to our farm to enjoy the
history and the beer and the Beautiful
Farm atmosphere and great food and um
I think in order for to get to your
question I think in order for inbev to
turn things around they're going to have
to do something drastic with with the
Bud Light brand and to make it the
iconic brand that my family built is
going to be very difficult for them to
do it in the situation that they're in
and I am serious as can be if they were
ever willing to spin off the Bud Light
brand or the Budweiser family Brands I
would be more than happy to buy them I
would be the first in line I think
bringing them back in the Bush family
would not only be a win for the Bush
family but it would also be a win for
America it would be a win for inbev that
would be very interesting Adam Billy
question for you I want to hear how you
would make Bud Light great again so you
know growing up in the 90s we all
remember the commercials they were
iconic what's up is he is he gone
okay there he is you know what's up or
you know you know to the real American
Heroes We Salute You and all this and
then you used to have the bud versus Bud
Light Super Bowl things like the frogs
everything it was awesome the
commercials were amazing right fast
forward sign of the times today you got
Dylan freaking Mulvaney as your
spokesperson and Vinny's like oh they I
think they lost a billion dollars tried
27 billion dollars sir not your fault I
get it but you know I saw you on Tommy
Lauren uh her podcast and you were like
look I just think they're out of touch
they're based in Brazil in Bev you you
told this awesome story but I think it
was your grandfather even 90 years old
getting in a truck meeting the guys
running bars just like you know like a
politician would getting out there
shaking hands kissing babies like
selling your beers selling your brand
and I just think there's a lot of things
that are out of touch you know a shout
out to Hall and Oates right there you
know fast forward to today there's a
video of our friend Tom who just asked
you a question Pat offered him a beer
he's like I want don't even touch it
like won't even touch it then you got
Kid Rock literally assassinating Bud
Lights it's like it's gone so extreme so
if you were to buy it back you know
right now Modelo is the number one beer
in America a freaking Mexican beer I
think inbev owns them as well so how
would you actually make Bud Light great
again
you know I would get out there on the
street I would meet with the bar owners
and the managers of the different
accounts that we sell the beer into like
I have been for the last uh several
years 10 years with the uh with the
former company and when I did it with um
the Budweiser distributorships get out
there meet people I would have everybody
that worked for me including the
marketing company get on a truck deliver
beer understand who their customer is
get out there get involved so that they
know who they're marketing to
um I don't think inbev I think I think
you know unfortunately for them they're
not an American American company like
you said Patrick and they don't
understand the American customer the
audience the drinks Bud Light they
haven't been out there uh selling the
beer like I was telling Tommy um you
know the how my father's still at 90
years old would go into a bar buy people
beers and let and shake hands and um
that's the way to do it and it comes
down to the old-fashioned uh way of
marketing the product you know there's
all kinds of ways to market today
there's so many different channels but
the basically uh my family always lived
by the statement making friends is our
business you got to get out there you
got to get amongst the people because
that's what beer drinking is all about
right it's all about bringing people
together being social inclusive and
having a great time and that's what the
campaigns and in history have been about
also the quality of the beer the
strength of the beer with the eight
horse hitch the Clydesdales was
something that was huge for
Anheuser-Busch and um you know that's
the kind of way I would go about it
again
um to to really get to make Bud Light
and the Budweiser Brands America's beer
once again what would you say to Dylan
Mulvaney if he uh was at the bar just
sitting there drinking a Bud Light would
you have anything to say to Dylan
Mulvaney I would say um let me buy you
one Dylan but listen um I'm not going to
use you as an influencer
um on our on our marketing ads you know
more power to you please uh I'm glad you
love Bud Light
um you know because please enjoy it with
your friends and your family and um I
don't think he actually loves Bud Light
I think he's sipping on Rose or some
sort of zinfandel all right let's tell
them if you have final thoughts we have
one last question I would you know what
you know I once you read that there were
10 iconic brands in America and I'm not
going to remember all of them but it was
coke Harley Davidson Ford Budweiser and
Chevrolet I think was on the list and I
think in many ways that the family
brought it back at a time where I think
America needs unity and maybe a return
to some of the the great iconic brands
of it I'd love to see this come back to
the family and so you did do something
strong with it awesome
awesome thank you Tom for that uh Billy
I want I want to finish with a legendary
quote by Dolphus Bush I think we have to
finish it the right way he once said you
can only drink 30 or 40 glasses of beer
a day no matter how rich you are so we
never got there it was the goal 23 is
our number Billy again thank you for
coming out folks watching this Rob let's
make sure we put the link below to his
book that just came out uh uh family
Reigns The extraordinary rise and the
Epic fall of an American Dynasty thank
you Billy uh uh that was fantastic great
to have him on and I think we lost them
but Billy if you're listening thank you
for coming on really enjoyed it
interesting to see what's going on my
whole thing is
you know if you're running a company
that's always known for having the best
commercials you do I mean when you're
going back and telling those stories but
wives ER you know hey what's up what's
up you know when you think about that to
go to this there has to be a set of
non-negotiables as the CO2 say anything
we're going to do that's against this
our core brand you need approval and for
it to happen without that it's kind of
weird and if you did approve it and you
did send it out and you're paying the
price for well you cost a company a lot
of money not a little bit of money a lot
of girls working right now the one that
would you think about it the one that is
apparently didn't get fired
she wouldn't fire 27 billion dollars
let's talk let's talk about Oprah and
rock so Oprah and rock uh decided to
come out with a message to say they have
the right way the way to be trusted to
give money to and if you give money
through them it will definitely be a
good decision to help out the people in
Maui Vinnie you have some thoughts to
say with this video it's all over the
place a lot of people are happy that
they did this column of noble a lot of
people are not happy about it what are
your thoughts okay so oh yeah first but
they made a video asking uh the average
Joe for money and I get Pat I give I
know you know we we go to the same
church I donate I give I give the family
I give the friends but it's pretty crazy
one of the facts that we saw that was a
great Sound by the way yeah I love the
Bud Light right there it's a vault
watermelon you've had too many of them
yeah these people oh it feels great
these people between her and The Rock
pack guess how rich they are just if you
had to guess on the book three and a
half billion exactly you nailed it and
from the stats that we showed on one of
the first stories the average American
especially like low income Pat except
what paycheck to paycheck 78 from 76
we're struggling but she's so concerned
if she's so concerned about these fires
and these people why did she fire uh she
hired a a private firefighting team to
protect her land uh before this all went
down right and instead Oprah just got
what 2 000 acres of land
Oprah if you're so concerned Why don't
you give up some of that land for some
of these displaced people so they could
stay because these people have nothing
they're struggling right now so why
don't you you know put your money where
your mouth and she hasn't mentioned Pat
that she bought all this land for
pennies on the dollar and I think it's
just how out of touch I I don't think
this is genuish uh genuine and I want to
give some facts just about Mommy really
uh Maui the government leaders they did
want to make it people were saying it's
a conspiracy they wanted to make this a
smart city but the locals didn't want to
sell they're like no this is our land
this is we don't want to sell it all of
a sudden this fire uh comes out right
and all these stories from the ground
from actual residents police blockaded
people with 18 wheelers and patrol cars
Pat so they couldn't get uh to their
land the government shut off the water
they canceled school and out of 3 000
missing 1 000 children have been
accounted for there are still 2 000
children and this is a fact I'm not
making this isn't I'm conspiracy
theorists that they're they're missing
nobody's talking about it the police
chief and I know we talked about it is
the same police chief that was in Vegas
during the Vegas Massacre he appointed
himself the coroner so you mean to tell
me that guy is the only person that
could see the the bodies and make a
determination of the cause of death it's
like this keeps piling up right uh and
all of a sudden yeah Zuckerberg Oprah
all these people buying all this land
and then as a military veteran Pat
there's a military base 15 minutes away
they weren't there until a week a week
and a half it's just none of it is
adding up and the FEMA holding back
water and everything like that and I
cannot tell you about how many videos
I'm seeing that you're not going to see
on social media you're not I mean you're
not going to see on
on Facebook on CNN and all this stuff
only on on X only on Twitter the people
are flipping losing their minds they all
are they're like something is up we
can't get to our land everything is
fenced off we're getting phone calls
from people saying we'll we'll buy your
land they basically uh that's why I'm
saying the Oprah and the Rock if you
watch this I it doesn't feel genuine I
don't feel it something is going
something something is up and I just
play the first 30 seconds let's just see
what Maui that we were texting back and
forth and I read this article that Dolly
Parton had given money in her community
and I said I think this is the answer
you said I think that's the answer I
said I love it and so we have created
The People's fund of Maui that will put
money directly in the hands of the
people who need it right now so if you
send a donation just click where you see
below and send a donation that money is
going to go to one of many residents who
have been displaced in Maui we guarantee
that's right I know a lot of people out
there as Oprah and I have been finding
are just having a hard time trusting
where the money goes what organizations
should I send money to how can I help in
this case can I say something too bad
yeah they're asking the average American
that can't pay rent living paycheck to
paycheck how about this Oprah why don't
you ask Biden or or the government hey
could we have one billion of the 200
million we sent to Ukraine and just give
it to them how about right now stop I
want one million I want one billion
dollars back and give it back to them
Packers apparently I heard something
true with this money that they she put
in money and he put in money they both
put in money they both put in money but
there's a loophole or something where
that money is going to their like the
organization it's not even coming out of
their pocket it's like if you can you
verify that because to me if they're
putting their own money
and then they're also raising money I
think it's uh you know it's you're at
least doing something with it right now
I mean you know is it enough money to
do anything more here let's just see
what's what it's saying Oprah and rock
uh angered some fans by asking them to
give Maui their own donations was less
than half a percent of their total
wealth can you go a little lower half a
percent of their total wealth so half a
percent is what three and a half billion
one percent would be 35 million so half
would be 17 and a half million so I see
what you're saying so that's kind of how
they calculate so the fans will jump to
donate more than 10 million dollars
but you feel me Pat like your this this
message is for the average American why
don't you go after the people that have
all the money I mean here's the thing
about giving money man you can never
give enough money never when you do give
any kind of money it's never enough if
you give a million they say why don't
you give two million if you give two
million they'll say why don't you give
five million So to that part I totally
understand where they're coming from I
didn't know they're not they're giving
money I thought they're not giving money
if they're giving 10 million dollars as
well from their own money to Maui you
know uh respect to them to the all the
other stuff the fact that that one girl
that went viral with the video tell us
why you hired a firefighters before the
fire even took place how did you know to
do that that's the stuff that we don't
know that needs to be investigated all
the other stuff you know they want to
bring the awareness
um no listen eventually what happens to
a lot of people they give money they
want to give anonymously and they don't
even want to be involved they're like
dude I don't want to event I'll give
something but just please don't tell
anybody because I know no matter what I
give will never be enough no matter what
I give will never be enough so go for it
and at what at what point Pat does
coincidence and conspiracy like where
are we at because if and I I I Googled
the definition coincidence is a
remarkable concurrence of events or
circumstances without a parent casual uh
uh happenings but conspiracy is a secret
plan by a group to do something unlawful
or harmful you we get we get looked upon
as these crazy I'm a conspiracy theorist
is it so crazy to see that these people
are making or they're doing something on
purpose how many mistakes have to happen
is it gross negligence Pat or was it set
up for them to lose all these are two
different issues I'm very skeptical what
happened on Maui I'm very skeptical what
the politicians did locally I'm very
skeptical why they didn't give the water
I'm very skeptical why it looks like it
doesn't look like fire it looks like
it's completely something else with the
dogs like looking in the way they did
I'm very skeptical why certain houses
didn't catch on fire within the
community of Maine I'm very skeptical of
that yes there could be two different uh
issues within the same event I'm super
skeptical about why the guy from Vegas
shooting Mandalay Bay is the guy that's
working on and now is the court assigns
himself that kind of stuff super
skeptical this kind of stuff you're
giving money is not enough you know get
in line everybody no matter how much you
ever give to to anyone they're always
going to say that's not enough that's
not enough that's enough so until we
find out more if they're given 10
million bucks more power to them can
they give more I'm sure they can they
don't have to it's their money they work
hard for it they're given a lot more
than the government is right now way
more than the government is right now
government's given 700 to the family so
uh good for those guys okay all right so
let's go into a couple other stories
here so uh which one do we want to go to
do we want to do politics today we
haven't hit any politics which one do
you want to go to Tom's got some
thoughts on this with Super PAC okay
so two things so the scientist team
denies Trump's rumor that he'll drop out
of the presidential race to run for
Senate this was a week ago on August
28th it's on page seven I'll read two
stories simultaneously then time I'm
going to give it to you
so the center spokesperson Brian Griffin
strongly refuted Trump's claim on Truth
social that the scientists could abandon
the presidential race for Senator Ron
saying on Twitter that it's fake news
and suggesting Trump's Army of
Consultants was anxious about the
sentences debate success Trump using the
moniker run the sanctimonious for
DeSantis propaganda propagated the
notion that rumors are strong on
political circles about the sentences
potential dropping out of the race
uh to V for Senator Rick Scott Senator
seat despite the sentence as recent
polling setbacks in an Emerson poll post
debate unveiled a 50 support uh rate for
Trump among GOP voters a six percent dip
from previous Paul whereas the centers
gained two points railing Trump at 50 to
12 and then the same to super camp super
Pax urgent plea to donors we need 50
million dollars this is a New York Times
story Rhonda Center Super PAC Never Back
Down led by strategist jeffrow urgently
six 50 million dollars from donors ahead
of the second GOP debate on September
27. we need to do this now we're making
a move now the day after Labor Day we're
launching and we need your help to stay
up and go hard uh the rest of the way we
need 50 million bucks Roe emphasizes the
need for 5 million monthly to sustain
Iowa operations separating separate from
Rivals and beat Donald J Trump in the
next 60 days we need to beat Trump in
the next 60 days separate from all his
other Rivals we need five million okay
same thing said twice okay go ahead Tom
thoughts on this
so let me split this for you when you
hear that the super Pacs are behind in
their support that means you're losing
your big donors because the way the game
is played you go out and create these
super Pacs because super Pacs are
unlimited if you wanted to give anything
now as a citizen you can only give 3 300
as an individual your wife could also
give 3 300. your children could even on
their own give 3 300 but that's it
beyond that you have to give money into
the Super Pacs and the super max go to
the billionaires and we've heard the
stories about this billionaires who
Trump these two billionaires are with
DeSantis and for them to be going out
and saying we need 5 million a month to
sustain Iowa and we need 50 million
right now is a incredibly bad sign
because the Super PAC money is usually
locked in early you have who your
supporters going to be we've heard Larry
Ellison looking to get behind one of
them you've heard the list this is not
good with this leak the the camp doesn't
not want this leak to come out citizens
are giving you know up to thirty three
hundred dollars usually 25 30 50 bucks
something like that this is a really bad
sign for The Campaign which means that
the super Pacs are losing the support of
the big donors and the big donors after
the debate and looking at the polls are
saying maybe I'm going to hold the big
money back because maybe this isn't the
guy that's going to challenge wow so wow
interesting that's my conclusion here by
the way it's a lot of people's
conclusions it's like if you were behind
them and just putting money in the Super
PAC let me ask you Pat
if you're in Super Pac and we won't say
to Santos we'll just say it was a
candidate and you're looking at this
kind of hey the debate did not give him
a 10-point pop and he's suffering an
erosion in certain groups what does that
make you think
you know hey I've been to the party I've
given some but I'm not going to chase it
I'm gonna wait for you to see if you can
really go get Iowa and he's saying I
need 5 million a month between now and
February to get Iowa if you follow the
trends and the stats and the polls I
mean what earlier this year they were
neck and neck I constantly say this it's
like they were neck and neck and due to
failed marketing and arrested
indictments that too it's turned into a
blowout so you know it's typical Trump
fashion I hear he's dropping out of the
race so here he's gonna be a center
there may or may not be any truth to
that whatsoever but believe me Trump
will pounce on the opportunity to Market
that story but what do you expect uh the
sentences people to do you know we've
met his spokesperson Brian Griffin not
the dog from Family Guy his uh his
spokesperson you know he's gonna hold
the fort and say no we're not dropping
out of the race but look at some point
the writing is going to be on the wall
you were neck and neck and now our guy
vivec is passing you up you were neck
and neck and now it's all about Vivek
so and I think as
to kind of give a bigger picture to this
as more of these the stats show and the
polls show as more and more indictments
come down the pike
it it's just codifying his firm grip on
the Republican Party the biggest
challenge Trump's going to have is
pivoting in the general election we get
it he's got the Republican nomination
unlock uh his closest uh opponents
DeSantis and ramaswami are nowhere to be
found especially in the polls uh so
you're saying that little what was it
pat we talked about it yesterday that
that uh the independent uh Tom that vote
in the middle that you were talking
about and like the African-American uh
uh support is Shifting towards Trump I
forgot that it went down from yeah well
it ain't it's not just yeah all I'm
seeing is people like you know what
we're tired of you know the government
you know doing this and doing that and
the support is Shifting well watch this
here from axios okay Trump World sees
Haley surging towards the santis and
according to this poll on Iowa Fabricio
poll depicted Trump leading with 44 the
Santa says 18 Haley at 10. and then it's
rambiswani and Tim Scott at seven in New
Hampshire Trump LED with 48 the census
11 Haley and Ramos one we had nine again
that's two percent and Scott tied with
former New Jersey Governor Christie at
five percent so they keep talking about
this whether you know he's getting
closer or not and this is leading to the
biggest question Trump supporters
pressure him to debate the scientists
this is a Newsweek article a survey
conducted between August 26 and 29
showed that while 61 percent of all GOP
voters and 83 percent of trump
supporters approved of his decision to
skip the first debate 57 of them now
overall believe Trump should take part
in the second debate to get scheduled uh
on September 27th I believe at the
Ronald Reagan Library in Simi Valley do
you think Trump should show to the
second debate time hell no still say no
hell no let these two JV guys battle it
out there's no like and what's this
there's no reason and what's this uh so
bad this debate is how many people on
stage whoever's still in the race
probably eight people I think the rules
are gonna drop the two Governors yeah
for sure no way I'm surprised
and Doug burgum yeah man that was my guy
bergam they got the sprained his angle
playing basketball I actually like this
ideas they're gonna drop and then um
also it looks like Tim Scott may be on
the edge of qualifying and here and
loser and but he may not decide to drop
but he may not be able to be on exactly
uh and so that's I just wanted to see
Trump Pence Christie DeSantis Vivek
Nikki Haley everyone else get out I
think Trump because Pat while we were
there we're like in that big you know
it's like an arena I just saw this big
GOP thing in the middle I just wish
Trump would have just descended like Ed
yeah air and just fireworks and then not
debate just leave like make an entrance
and then leave in the back here's my
question though does the Democratic
party not debate at all are they not
they have no no no but you have uh
debate why is that because it's called
the foreign
like right now if you look at the the
store so Tom you think Trump should show
up second one or no no I don't think you
should show up don't because only thing
that happens if he shows up is he gets
picked on I think he should let the
crowd continually to hit themselves
because it is a fact everybody was
screaming well Trump lost six points in
in in Iowa true but Haley took
um apparently four of her points
demonstrably were taken from DeSantis
supporters that moved over because they
saw Schmid a strong case I think he lets
that continue to shake out and I think
in the Santa's campaign I think the
writing is on the wall but with your
back back up against the wall you can't
see the writing and I think that's
around to Santa by the way just refresh
remember in 2020 did Trump do any
debates against any uh Republican
contenders I don't think so I don't I
don't think Obama did I don't think it's
very good incumbent president you're
right it's not the only thing that's
different is the following and I'll tell
you what it is there's this guy named
Gavin Newsom I don't know if you know
him or not his movie he started his
like on energy is a sign he's
running for something Washington Times
this is a September third story so
Governor Newsom is strongly signaling a
presidential run likely in 2024 by 2020
a position himself as a more capable
alternative to the current Democratic
ticket Newsome's shift away from the
traditional environmental stances is
evident as he prioritizes ensuring
consistent electricity Supply and
avoiding surging energy costs notably he
is advocating for increased natural gas
storage at the alisso canyon facility
despite the history its history of a
major methane leak in 2015 this move
aligns with his focus on practical
Energy Solutions over rigid rigid
ideological Purity knew some strategic
decisions including expanding natural
gas storage and keeping the Diablo
Canyon Nuclear Plant operational
underscore his commitment to maintaining
energy to reliability and affordability
for Citizens town so what he's doing
here is Gavin Newsom is still all about
green energy but right now the green
energy is dollars and making it cost
less for Californians that's his green
energy program so Aliso Canyon has
needed to be retrofit for a while and he
wants to store gas there so if there's a
shortage over the winter and California
doesn't have winners but they do have
shortage points and so he also doesn't
want Diablo Canyon to turn down it's a
megawatt output and so what he's saying
is yeah look I can't have the people in
California have their price for Energy
go up because we have a shortage of
energy we're not going to have cold
Winters we don't have heating oil but
you know what I'm going to back off this
whole green thing and I'm going to
quietly do things so that we have energy
storage in California for the benefit of
the people and it's also
anti-inflationary now I happen to think
that as a governor he's putting the the
needs of the people first and trying to
get them less expensive energy but it
sort of flies in the face of going arm
and arm with the green energy mob in in
Washington so it's a bit two-faced but
it's actually going to be good for
Californians that want to have a little
less
inflation on their energy over the next
nine months but his motive is different
I think you you knock the energy part
out of the out of the park
um
I think he's just sort of waiting in the
wings as an insurance plan God forbid
Biden is not able to make it and that's
a you know very substantive possibility
make it in what sense though you mean
like just meaning heels over falls on
another flight of stairs correct oh you
really think you really believe that
like he might not make it till next year
you want to bet that Joe Biden finishes
his term
another 500 bucks you have a deal you
think he's gonna die or something so let
me flip it over do you understand what
it means to finish your term he means
he's gonna finish his term as president
he's not gonna die Oh you mean you mean
go another four no no no do you
understand what he's the president yeah
you're saying yeah he has one more year
left yeah he's gonna finish it yeah I
know okay that's why I'm betting you
guys are saying the same thing you guys
are saying the same stupid Adam what do
you mean so you're not I'm saying he
will he's like okay okay so this
biography his biography brain function
it wouldn't be total shock if Biden
drops out of the 2024 race my concern is
not Biden finishes the term I have a bet
Byron Udell Jake Goodell's Dad if you're
listening wait a bet in 2020 one of the
first uh pbd podcasts
um whether Biden would finish his
tournament is not I'm like yeah he's
gonna finish his turn of course he might
be old and sick and weakened at Bernie's
Vibes yeah but they'll prop his ass up
and he'll finish his term so I have a
thousand dollar bet with him I think
he'll finish Aaron can we get can we get
uh Joe Biden's address on send him a
case of all to drinks
the biggest concern should in fact be
the second term
for all of those people out there saying
it is dementia and he's sick and he's
falling down stairs I hear you loud and
clear he's going to finish his term the
moment is true all of them should be the
second term because the last thing we
need is Kamala Harris becoming president
United States Hillary Clinton would flip
the flip our lid if Kamala Harris or as
Judge Joe Brown calls her come alive
Harris became the uh first female
president but listen even when space
even yeah space even so big because
Trump was in like I mean you saw you saw
Pence he spoke a lot not too crazy but
like Kamala Harris besides laughing like
where's she I haven't even seen her in
like a month where is she Tom what are
you doing she's been busy delivering
funeral wreaths around the world which
is where they send most vice presidents
when they don't want him to be let me
ask you guys back to the Goodwill tour
to booger Club Yugoslavia or something
um what's the word on their debate
because I think Newson was just doing
this to make himself relevant stay in
the fold keep his name out there God
forbid Biden can't run
2024 you know it's a bad look for
descent to paid Newsome
what are you doing what are you doing
you're running for president he's not
why are you debating a person that's not
not running for president what are you
doing like what's your outcome what are
you doing it's embarrassing you
shouldn't even do it you shouldn't even
agree to it yeah it's actually a pompous
and arrogant to say yeah we're gonna run
because we feel we're the future anyways
and you guys are old it's a little bit
disrespectful on the way uh uh anyways I
don't want to get into that part I I did
not like that uh uh positioning while
you're running for president you do now
if you do it while nobody's running for
president now let's just say they did it
in 2022 the peak of covet 21. great I
totally agree do it yeah yeah not right
now you're two years too late two years
ago would have been a fantastic debate
the world would have watched it would
have been massive and would have helped
the santis out by the way if they would
have done it two years ago but right now
there's no reason no by the way can we
just give a quick shout out to our good
old friend Mitch McConnell good to see
that he's back functioning uh and uh not
a uh I don't know what is going on
Frozen like uh what is going on with
that guy I don't know I I don't because
this is the second time man it's like
the handlers that are around him it's
like what what why you you just can't
you can't give up that power right
because who's who's who's who's how do
you not know he's not meditating how do
you not know he's not praying I why do
you why do you undermine such a
experienced wise man maybe the entire
time he's praying for every person
that's representing their new station
there I think he's a living example of a
zoom Club
I think today I'm gonna post a sketch on
valuetainment comedy of we'll look at
pause it right there of what he's
looking at it'll be a little surprise to
you but he's let's that look he look and
then he's looking up to like up here
Heavenly Father like you don't pray for
president like this God is like you're
gone
did he just freeze are you there yes
yeah I know we're poking fun
no I am we all are it's sad but this is
a guy literally uh four people away from
the presidents he's the Senate minority
leader he was the majority leader for
years by the way if you look at the
stats in the polls least favorable
politician least favorable Senator so
the people of Kentucky shout out to the
Kentucky Wildcats you guys know a lot of
a lot of college players that are one
and done that's like the best college
basketball school one and done this guy
should be one and done years ago time to
get him out okay who would take a spot
who takes the spot the atom sounds to be
he's pretty interested in wanting to do
something like that but anyways gank
it's been great being with you guys uh
Rob what else we got this week podcast
wise Mike we're back Thursday okay
sounds good we will be back Thursday
take care everybody